so i wanted to talk about feral girl
summer uh which i saw in the independent
a little while ago feral girl summer is
the latest dating trend to make single
uh single women feel inadequate a new
tic-toc trend is encouraging women to
embrace their authentic selves but what
does it say about the pressures society
places on women without partners so as
you might be aware hot girl summer was a
thing that was promoted was it by
who did it megan this megan d stallion
uh to capture the post-pandemic spirit
of last year trended on tick tock and
instagram hot girl summer uh and feral
girl summer is about not shaving your
legs
it's about thinking it think fleabag
with a sprinkle of someone who has been
at glastonbury for three weeks
ostensibly the feral girl summer is not
about dating but as with hot girl summer
its definition is dependent on it
according to the dating app badou 87 of
female users felt pressured to have a
hot girl summer in 2021 with 71 saying
that this impacted their dating life so
feral girls summer is whatever the
opposite is of hot girl summer it's
talking about female autonomy it's not
giving a [ __ ] the attitude is similar to
that perpetuated by the cool girl trope
problematic yet this seductive depiction
of subdued femininity created for the
male gaze so this is somehow this is a
trend created by women for women but has
somehow been uh
screwed back around to it being a
product of the patriarchy and it's
oppressive cis heteronormative is that
what they're saying that it's a product
of the patriarchy oh everything is uh
similar another tick tick tock trend
goblin mode
no i like that though goblin mode the
feral girl summer encourages women to
forego beauty rituals in favor of more
radicalized unkempt aesthetics you have
to be your authentic self in order to
qualify and that apparently means
throwing away your razor why because
conforming to beauty standards makes us
makes us bad feminist is having hairy
legs supposed to make us feel empowered
when we have sex and if it doesn't does
that make us a failure so basically it's
a very unfalsifiable
idea that womanhood is um
archaic ideologies around womanhood and
this is something that's put forward by
men you go well
look at where most of the criticism
about women's appearances come from
it's not men
it's mostly other women
men criticize men and women criticize
women that doesn't mean that there isn't
crossover but beauty standards
for women
aren't created by men we don't give a
[ __ ] about your new fast fashion and
whether pastel shades are in and whether
you remember a thigh gap when a thigh
gap was a thing
and now it's whether you've got like a
big a big bum
all of that came from women
to women it wasn't us but the feral girl
summer thing i just think is it's very
very interesting because
it's
always it's showing very quickly this
sort of vacillation from one extreme to
another hot girl summer was supposed to
be the pandemics locked everybody down
summer's here you're supposed to be your
best self and go out and be glamorous
with your friends and go to festivals
and wear white boots and stuff like that
within one year
it's now whatever the exact opposite is
well it makes sense they're really the
same energy
how do you mean like so it's the same
it's like they're actually not only yeah
they're two sides of the same coin right
so it's really the same
i i totally relate to the idea of of
trying to
trying to look a certain way
right i mean my whole life have been so
aesthetically minded but like not like
with necessarily good aesthetics right i
was like a hardcore kid in the bay area
all black and
you know i had like a neck full of
handmade beaded necklaces that showed
you how straight edge i was or something
like you have the black cross on the
back of the hand when we went to shows
sure let's go yeah so but like
the aesthetics like my brother says i
took myself out of the game
before i was before it even started
right like
um
they're the same they're they're the
same energy
because
back to the bit about authenticity
like you're
you you have to kind of know yourself a
little bit to try to be honest about
your inauthenticity
and i think it's actually quite hard to
be honest about your inauthenticity
um to even
to even grock it in any sort of way
right it's like it's actually kind of
running in the background a bit and it's
hard to to get back then it's harder to
get back there than it is to like try
something like this which is very clear
be hot this which is very clear be not
hot you know it's like oh this is this
feels like the same thing b you know b
maybe she's born with it maybe it's
maybelline it's like b maybe it's hairy
legs maybe it's under armpits yeah
there's a really cool uh thing i learned
about mimetic theory so you know mimesis
right rene gerard's thing um people copy
people that are of high status right
megan the stallion
high enough status to cause
millions probably of girls to think
about having a hot girl summer last year
now there's two types of mimesis i
didn't know this one is positive mimesis
which is when you model off somebody
that's high status the other is negative
mimesis which is when you don't model
off somebody that's low status so the
problem with trying to be a
contrarian or a heterodox or a cynic or
a skeptic a lot of the time that's no
more
nuanced or depth thinking
than the other person or if if
all that you do is reflexively be
contrarian to whatever the mainstream
narrative is
that that's no smarter than the people
that just follow it you've just inverted
whatever the algorithm is if it's the
same with you know what happened with
the vaccines and stuff like that that
caused a lot of people to be so
distrusting of mainstream media because
they'd seen them sort of flip-flop
between different narratives a lot that
they became reflexive contrarians and
you go hang on do you really think that
the opposite
unthinkingly the opposite of whatever
the mainstream says is somehow a more
nuanced
position than simply following it it's
literally the exact position inverted
yeah and i heard you speak of that
before that sort of reflexive
contrarian-ness and it's something i
really relate to i've like i i've
experienced that a lot like my my mind
my head sounds like that often or when i
look back
over life and and see
full like seasons or phases of my life
that were lived in some things
that were that were just inspired by not
being like that yep i mean that's what
this is in fact we've that i think
that's a really good explanation for
what it is it's two sides of the same
coin you had hot girl summer last year
feral girl summer this year and it's the
contra it's the reflexive contrarian
thing last year we were playing up to
what men's standards were in terms of an
oppressive it was created by megan the
stallion not a man uh therefore this
year we're going to disregard uh typical
feminine beauty standards and you go by
hang on a second when you don't feel
nice
when you do that
that's also not that's not coming from
some [ __ ] bureaucratic organization
telling you about how you're supposed to
be it's just naturally what's in the
culture at the moment about what is
femininity and for the most part that's
created by women and this reflexive
heterodoxy reflexive cynicism skepticism
thing
it it really isn't a smart solution it's
no deeper but it gives people a little
bit more of a sense that they've done
some work right and it but it's like i
don't even believe this
i don't even believe in this world
anymore this world of bloggers talking
to each other about who's responsible
for this that any other first of all i
bet there's like
in terms of meaningful numbers of people
who are and they were like
thinking that this hot girl or feral
girl summer is important it's like very
minimal in terms of its significance i
imagine i think you'd be surprised maybe
when it gets down to the girls level
like that
people want a
archetype to latch on to you know this
yeah you know this the stories
throughout the ages
they want an archetype yeah but i guess
sometimes it's just like when it's 20
year olds like
like
oh my god screaming about screaming
about like i'm like
call me in like eight years like we're
gonna we're gonna get through some real
[ __ ] you've gotta leave let's like life
keeps going it just keeps going yeah
right yeah like you're having feral girl
for a summer you're having a hot girl
for a summer
well i mean that's a good point the fact
that
what you do for the summer is a really
important thing
only somebody that's been around on the
planet for less than 20 years can think
that that's a big deal possibly i mean i
love the idea that you can try on
different [ __ ] we can try on all of this
stuff and cool go explore
try a bunch of stuff on right and
realize how maybe not closer to who you
how you want to feel you still are like
it's like that jim carrey quote about i
hope you get everything that you want
and then realize like you still don't
have it
you know like you're still missing some
essential
[ __ ]
i'm around a lot of women who are who
are consciously not not shaving have you
ever shaved your legs by the way no have
you yeah right how does it feel
oh dude so you had a hot girl summer i
had a very hot girl summer back in the
day
these are like these legs these these
leg hairs are like tree trunks by the
way i would only go up halfway through
my thigh because it's a nightmare going
higher i literally had hair
shorts i mean just getting
there's just more thick hair up there
hilarious but i just loved getting into
bed with a clean shaved leg it you never
felt anything like it and then you get
one chill
and
all these little pricks start showing up
and it's done
it's over turkey that's so unplugged i
relate to the like to like i don't want
to be shaving my legs anymore right i
relate to that so much even though i
like that was you know i had my hot it
was just a summer i was doing that uh
but it was i highly recommend i have a
buddy who does that from uh jujitsu
because he's adamant that it helps him
with leg lock escapes there you go
certainly it makes it more slippery yeah
exactly what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace